[Musica]
chi di voi ha letto il libro uomo di
michelle and
parla di questi uomini grigi che nel set
nel segno dell'efficienza gestiscono la
banca del tempo ma prima nel mondo di
vitalità colore e le ben freud e ci
ricorda che c'è bisogno di
partecipazione appartenenza
coinvolgimento energia che per quanto
necessari
professionalità preparazione rigore
tecnicismo il mancato coinvolgimento può
finire per creare un distaccamento del
sistema e quindi togliergli la
legittimità
è in quest'ottica che oggi parlando di
ricchezza e povertà mi viene da fare
l'analogia tra politica e finanza
ma non solo per l'importanza che
entrambe ricoprono a livello sistemico
per la società e dell'economia
ma anche per ciò di cui entrambe
soffrono cioè l'esaurimento del
carburante che permette loro di
funzionare la fiducia
ci ho riflettuto facendo una delle cose
che più mi piace fare a londra andare in
un comedy club in cui è tra le varie
esibizioni di comici più o meno
improvvisati
il presentatore sceglie le sue vittime
nelle prime file per quello le più
temute e fa domande per per le sue
battute prende ispirazione per le sue
battute e ogni volta un bancario della
city prova a districarsi dalle domande
sul suo lavoro e cioè tra tra tra i
fischi e i commenti degli insulti quasi
del pubblico e questo conferma ciò che
vediamo anche altrove infatti il
rapporto del rapporto pubblicato
annualmente dall espresso sul sugli
atteggiamenti degli italiani nei
confronti delle istituzioni
ci dice che stabilmente le tre
istituzioni che
più che meno sono considerate degne di
fiducia sono appunto le banche il
parlamento ei partiti in quest'ordine
questo è un trend stabile e che si
osserva anche in altri paesi però i
bancari non si eleggono quindi poco male
no nel senso operano volentieri al di
fuori dei riflettori
e a giudicare dalle cronache dalle loro
azioni non sembrano troppo interessati a
conquistarsi la nostra provazione perché
non hanno bisogno di approvazione e
dunque la legittimità democratica visto
che non è quella che governa il loro
sistema
sembra non contare cioè sono altri i
numeri che contano non in ogni voti ma i
profitti
eppure la finanza come come ogni altro
settore economico per quanto non sia
governata dal consenso democratico ha
comunque bisogno di di una licenza
sociale ad operare cioè una specie di
contratto che le garantisce di poter
operare all'interno della società c'è un
contratto sociale
e questa licenza è stabile però viene di
tanto in tanto rinegoziata e lo vediamo
nella storia quando interi settori
economici vengono portati fuori dal
mercato nero oppure vengano
liberalizzati oppure fortemente
regolamentati e così via e quindi ecco
cosa è accettabile e cosa non lo è e
ovviamente qualcosa che non è statico ma
che si evolve e ora non sto per niente
preannunciando alla fine del sistema
finanziario tutt'altro però quello che
voglio dire è che c'è chi ha colto i
campanelli d'allarme
ci sono venute diverse sul fatto se un
sistema possa riformarsi da solo oppure
no però quello che è chiaro con intense
con intento riformista oppure difensivo
è che la finanza si è resa conto del
fatto che la sua finale la sua licenza
sociale ad operare che la sua licenza ha
iniziato a scricchiolare ed ha iniziato
ad agire
avete mai sentito parlare di finanza
sostenibile
quando inizialmente pronunciavo queste
due parole la reazione era quasi
divertita cioè come se si trattasse di
uno stimolo
con la crescita esponenziale del settore
e forse soprattutto con il mainstreaming
delle considerazioni di possibilità
nella finanza tradizionale è un mondo di
cui si sente sempre più parlare però
quella diffidenza
rimane e da un nome green machine è un
nome che abbiamo sentito nominare più
volte
e il greenwashing lo sappiamo però è
quando un'azienda presenta come eco
sostenibili le proprie attività
occultandone l'impatto ambientale
negativo e quando pittura di verde ciò
che fa
solo un avvocato del diavolo può provare
a difendere il greenwashing però il mio
ragionamento questa sera e provare a
mettere un po nell'ottica di questa
fiducia mancanza di fiducia e di questa
licenza sociale ad operare
certamente più green washing più green
washing smascherato soprattutto però
della poca fiducia rimasta però è anche
una cartina al tornasole che ci dice
chiaramente che il sistema ha capito che
c'è una forte pressione dall'esterno una
forte pressione a rinegoziare questa
licenza e questa pressione continua a
crescere a partire dalla crisi
finanziaria globale in poi con occhio
pie wall street e adesso con i file ei
suoi futures che sempre di più
esplicitano l'inadeguatezza e anche la
mancata presa di responsabilità del
sistema finanziario e non solo nel
contribuire alla lotta ai cambiamenti
climatici
perché mente solo chi vuole apparire
diverso chi si rende conto di non
corrispondere alle aspettative
quindi la così grande presenza appunto
del boxing e la prova del nove
del fatto che l'importante che la
finanza riconosce l'importanza della
fiducia e come dicevo la sua
inadeguatezza
e prova anche oltre prova a capire fino
a che punto
dove si pongono questi nuovi standard
questi nuovi limiti di questa licenza
che altrimenti rischia di perdere quindi
come lo fa lo fa in un'ottica che
coinvolge entrambi i lati della
cosiddetta doppia materialità
il primo il primo lato è ciò che è
considerato materiale quindi
significativo da un punto di vista
economico finanziario che è quello più
diffuso in pratica dentro questo
approccio si riconosce che questi
fattori
di fattori ambientali sociali e di
governance hanno un impatto materiale
però sui propri rendimenti quindi si
dichiara se si analizzano si misurano si
analizzano si dichiarano e si prova a
mitigarli e vediamo che c'è una crescita
esponenziale dei fondi gestiti con i
criteri e quindi e per l'ambiente s
sociale g di governance
sono intorno ai circa 35 mila miliardi
con proiezioni per il 2025 di 50.000
miliardi quindi circa un terzo di tutti
i beni gestiti e la metà sono circa la
metà sono in europa però è un mettersi
in pari cioè come dicevo prima e provare
a raggiungere
sentire dov'è l'asticella perché in
realtà non sono fattori nuovi e quindi è
semplicemente integrare questi fattori è
semplicemente ammettere che una buona
gestione del rischio non può prescindere
da un'analisi e una mitigazione dei
rischi ambientali sociali e di cattiva
governance cioè un investitore
responsabile quindi un investitore che
ha a cuore il suo dovere fiduciario nei
confronti dei beni
cammini dei beneficiari dei beni che
amministra quindi pensiamo per esempio
un fondo pensione deve voler sapere se
le fabbriche delle aziende in cui
investe sono esposti a un rischio
d'inondazione e deve voler essere in
grado di quantificare quel rischio
quindi questo sta accadendo in vari modi
però in questo già un buon inizio
però chiaramente non è abbastanza per
mettersi in pari con le aspettative
della società che stanno cambiando e
paradossalmente più questi fattori sono
compresi vengono alla luce
essi ci si rende conto di quanto sono
significativi pensiamo gli eventi
atmosferici che stanno sempre più forte
intensità e frequenza anche i regolatori
e supervisori quindi gli arbitri del
sistema hanno cambiate le valore le loro
aspettative e così l'ha cambiata anche
il mercato quindi in questa licenza
sociale ad operare
questi aspetti si riflettono su tutti
gli stakeholder che partecipano al
sistema pensiamo in termini di
attrattività del lavoro è cosa risaputa
che i millennials non vogliono andare a
lavorare per certo un certo tipo di
azienda o per alcuni settori gli
investitori gli azionisti sempre di più
considerano e quindi il mercato
questi elementi che ha un impatto sul
costo del capitale
infine come dicevo prima i legislatori
ai regolatori che devono in teoria
assicurare gli obiettivi collettivi e
controllare il funzionamento del mercato
e tutti noi quando pensiamo alla
reputazione
l'opinione pubblica ma anche noi
individualmente come consumatori
influenziamo le categorie precedenti
quindi
detto tutto ciò per fortuna ci sono
alcuni investitori che si spingono oltre
si spingono oltre e considerano anche
l'altra parte da doppia materialità
quella verso l'esterno cioè
l'impatto che le proprie operazioni
hanno sul mondo che le circonda e quindi
declinato i tre fattori di cui parlavo
prima l'aspetto ambientale sociale e di
buona governance
alcuni provano essere e quindi alcuni
fondi provano essere trasparenti
riguardo al proprio impatto negativo a
limitarlo e se possibile anche essere
innovativi nel come avere un impatto
positivo non solo nel non avere un
impatto negativo
la conseguenza è che è cambiato anche il
marketing
e la narrativa con cui la finanza si
racconta
i siti web e le brochure non sono più
bene di grattacieli uomini in cravatta
ma di montagne campi pale eoliche
però per assicurarci che non sia tutto
solo greenwashing come parlavano
dicevano prima essenziale innanzitutto
parlare la stessa lingua quindi come
ormai noto alle cronache c'è un grande
lavoro e un faticoso lavoro per
sviluppare delle tazione mie e dicano
chiaramente cosa è verde e cosa non lo è
che è la base il passo successivo
è scrivere delle regole che chiariscono
cosa debbono e prima ancora cosa possono
fare gli operatori finanziari e che di
fatto è scrivere i termini di quella
licenza cioè negoziare e scrivere nero
su bianco quali sono in termini di
questa licenza e infine per assicurare
il controllo di queste norme e poi di
nuovo ruolo dei regolatori però in
realtà ci riguarda pensiamo per esempio
perché un prodotto finanziario può
rivendicare di fatto di salvare il mondo
senza nemmeno essere sottoposto
all'analisi
sia del mercato che dei regolatori
quando mai potrebbe dire ti rendo ricco
domani mattina
e quindi la chiave trasparenza onestà e
account belize e per quello l'aspetto
della governance fondamentale non solo
della governance in senso buona gestione
delle imprese in cui investi degli
investitori in sé ma anche della
governance degli aspetti di
sostenibilità come le aziende
approcciano questo
degli operatori finanziari approccio
questo questa sfida quindi tutto questo
dibattito sul green washing che molto
attuale ci dice che per rinegoziare la
sua licenza
la società esige che la finanza si renda
più verde inclusiva e trasparente e che
non solo rende a se stessa più
sostenibile ma che contribuisca alle
sfide attuali
prima tra tutte quella climatica di cui
c'è stremo bisogno
però la società non è disposta a dare
assegni in bianco sulla fiducia appunto
c'è scarsa non accetta
una certa più che la finanza sia la
causa del problema come nella crisi
scorsa ma si aspetta che sia parte della
soluzione alla crisi attuale quindi
quella climatica
e infine per tornare al mio punto
iniziale uno dei modi in cui momo riesce
a salvare il suo mondo e ascoltando se
gli uomini grigi della finanza
riusciranno ad ascoltare questa
richiesta il sistema potrà finalmente
riguadagnarsi la fiducia è una nuova
licenza sociale ad operare grazie